at a certain level you can say that you
know because global warming could harm
many of our lifestyles they could
actually jeopardize the lives of people
that it would implicate human rights but
I don't see a big advantage to calling
this a human rights issue you know it's
it's sufficient to say that global
warming is an enormous environmental
problem something we need to deal with I
don't see huge value added to say oh and
by the way it implicates the right to
life or the right to health care or the
right to you know this or that or even a
right to a clean environment I mean
adding that rhetorical right it's
language doesn't add appreciable weight
to the arguments against global warming
so there is a tendency to view rights as
the trump card that you know will sort
of get you to prevail in any political
conflict but but there are limits to
that and I don't see tremendous value
added on the issue of global warming it
becomes to say governments for pressing
environmental activists or if it that's
the rights issue it becomes just say you
know governments shutting down the press
so that the press won't report on their
environmentally destructive logging or
their environmentally destructive
farming practices or what-have-you
those are rights issues there are many
ways in which the human rights cause can
advance the environmental movement or
many other movements but that doesn't
mean that you have to treat every
movement as a rights issue in and of
itself there's a risk of of cheapening
the concept of Rights which which we
need to protect as a as a kind of a core
element and it doesn't end
you